♪ ♪ ♪
- Le Musée royal de l'riririo
est connu pour ses dinosaures.se
permanente, ce n'est pas
ces impressionnantes créatures
que le Musée met de l'avant,
mais plutôt les organismes
qui les ont précédés.RNRNRNRNRN,
conservateur en paléontologie
- L'histoire de la vie
avant les dinosaures,
ce sont des pérarararararararar.
- Dans cette galerie,
intitulée "L'aube de la vie",
les visiteurs font un retour
de 4le passé grâce à l'expositin
d'un millier de fossiles.
- Ce sont des fossiles
qui nous donnent une histoire
des animaux et aussi
de nos origines.
viennent du Canada et de zones
montag, , , , comme les schistes
de Burgess, en Colombie-
Britannique.
- Le Musée royal de l'Ontario
a co    à faire
des recherches sur ce site-là
en 1975, et aujourd'hui, on a l.
mise en valeur avec ses fossiles
uniques datant d'uioioioiode
glaciaire.
la première extinction de masse
de l'histoire de la vie.
promenade, les visiteurs
rererererent d'autres épisodes
climatiques extrêmes
qui ont mené à la destructs.s.s.
Pour Jean-Bernard Caron,des par.
- C'est une réflexion
sur la protection de njojojojoj.
Si une espèce s'éteint,
c'est des millions d'années
d'évolution qui s'éteignent,
c'est pas juste
m m m m misant sur de nombreux
outils interactifs, le Musée
royal de l'Ontario espéraiteueu.
Un pari visiblement remporté,
quoique les parents y trouvent
"C'est bien parce que
ça nous force à utiliser notre
Jean-Bernard Caron, le
paléontologue s'étantttttt
une passion pour les fossiles
à l'âge de 9 ans.
qui vont vouloir devenir
paléontologue,tttttt
paléontologue dans le futur.
- Il aura fallu une décennie
cette galerie, qui restera
ouverte inininininins 30 ans.
Radio-Canada, Toronto